talk about snake island and the
importance of it what actually happened
there and why is it so important yeah
snake island um it's in a strategically
important position
it's got a very ancient history it
features in greek mythology quite a lot
achilles and patroclus were said to be
buried there however um it is
strategically important because it
controls the air route and the sea route
in and out of odessa so whoever controls
snake island is in a position to do
something about odessa and if we're
talking about grain shipments out of
odessa then uh getting the russians away
from snake island is probably a big plus
for the ukrainians but they've been
fighting over snake island since day one
as we've mentioned many many times and
the russians have having taken the
island they installed anti-aircraft and
anti-missile defenses on the island the
ukrainians kept attacking them they they
uh were able to sink quite a lot of
ships but eventually the russians got
all this stuff onto snake island
once they got missile and air defenses
there they didn't think the ukrainians
would actually push them off it but the
ukrainians have pushed them off it by
using not missiles and aircraft but good
old-fashioned artillery and what they've
done is use their new
155 millimeter artillery mainly the
french system the howitzer the caesar
howitzer they the ukrainians have their
own cause it's called a badania
a badani system but they've only got one
or two of them very very new they might
have used them but much more likely it
was this the french caesar howard and
the point is that this how it survives
quite a lot of shells and with shells
that are called base bleed shells these
are shells which reduce the um the
vacuum behind the shell allows the shell
to go that little bit further so with
base bleed shells they have a
range of 42 kilometers and that's just
just enough to reach snake island from
the ukrainian mainland and that's what
they've done so they've managed it with
these sorts of systems and they've made
it impossible effectively for the
russians to stay on snake island
okay so that's snake island and odessa
let's look to the east um
this is obviously so much talk about
that
what is happening there what do we know
yeah the ukrainians they they withdrew
from severely done yet which we always
knew that they would they fought for
three three weeks longer than people
thought they might and probably they
thought they would and they've withdrawn
to lichishansk and that's a good
defensive position high ground on the
eastern the western side of the river
and they've got quite strong positions
there the russians be very lucky to get
over the river and attack the shishans
but what the russians have been able to
do is get round the back finally the
russians have crossed the river severe
cevsky donetsk in force they're
attacking the oil refinery and the point
about the oil refinery is that it's
southwest of lichishans
if they take the refinery which is a
natural fortress any big um
industrial facility can be made into a
fortress that's what ukrainians have
done if the russians take it and they
are saying that they have taken it
that's entirely plausible then they can
actually close that gap quite easily
they can surround the ukrainians so the
ukrainians will have to withdraw from
the chance probably more quickly and
further than they might have anticipated
and the road from bakmut down in the
southwest here which was the main line
of communication intelishishansk that is
now under enormous threat that fought
over it you know on and off now for
weeks and so i suspect that the
ukrainians are on the verge of having to
withdraw further westwards where they
will make their next stand i'm sure in
slavyansk and kramatowsk